[MUSIC PLAYING]
I guess how to get a data-driven
learning-based approach
to work on real robots.
I don't know.
I mean, I guess AGI is one
of these things that's like,
if you did solve it, it
would be truly a landmark.
I guess in my field, that
is the absolute holy grail.
And people have
theorems that show
that these kinds of
AGI systems might even
exist in certain ways.
But others debate it.
Others say that you might
never get an AGI system.
But I think that something
along those lines,
at least in the field
of machine learning,
would be one of the
greatest unsolved problems
that you could tackle.
My interests often
fall into places
where technology and humans
interact and have overlap.
And I think that this is going
to be true regardless of where
and when we are, but creating
equitable spaces in technology
that do minimal harm
and give people voices.
I think that across the
board, that's very difficult.
The current place that we see
that the most right now, I
think, is the machine learning.
So machine learning,
in fairness,
is really, really hot.
But there are other
places where that's true.
If you think about
just user experiences,
if you think about
your iPhone, the needs
of someone who is much older,
who's in a geriatric facility,
for example, are significantly
different than what someone
in their 20s or 40s or 50s.
I think one of the most
important unsolved problems,
but also possibly
unsolvable problems,
is figuring out
how to get machines
to better interact with humans
or how to develop the machinery
to understand how
humans will interact
with machines or algorithms.
I think that we're starting
to use incredibly complicated
systems all over the place.
And to me, the
complicated problem
is the integration of
these complex systems that
have bugs and problems
with human beings
because humans, ultimately, are
the ones who are using the code
and making decisions based
off of the recommendations
that the code gives them.
And I think thinking about
how code interacts with people
is just such an open question.
So when I think of this question
in terms of the hot topics
these days, machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
most of the stuff is
limited by our capabilities
as humans because, especially
for supervised learning
methods, we need to provide
some sort of data set.
And that data set is
usually labeled by humans.
So if you want to go beyond
that and explore intelligence
beyond human
intelligence, then we
need to think about new
ways, different ways,
that we might not even
be able to perceive.
So I think that's going
to be the next challenge
in the next decades.
Understanding when your
model is no longer going
to work before seeing
labels for that is,
I think, incredibly important.
We have lots of tools
to say, if I know this--
if I see the data comes out
of this kind of machine,
make the model work
while given that data.
But what happens in the wild
when things arbitrarily change
is still very hard
to understand.
And I think is a key
bottleneck to really making
intelligent systems
society scale.
So SafeML, I think, is
still open, fun challenge.
Yeah.
I think what's interesting
in my particular field, which
is about how to make robots,
is that there isn't really
one existing problem that
everyone is trying to solve.
It's more that people
are trying to figure out
new problems to define and then
proceed to solve them that way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]